31 are currently in hospital I threw
that eight still missing and three have
been discharged from hospital today our
focus will be on working with the boots
Safety's for us to tune those people
missing we will be relying on advice
coming from scientific and technical
committee and Wellington
they will who are currently meeting at
the moment and hope to hear further
advice on when we may potentially return
to the islands but I will reiterate I do
want to acknowledge the enormous
extraordinary work that's gone on
through that night to bring as much
information as as possible to everyone
this morning at this stage we can
confirm that amongst those currently
listed as missing or injured New
Zealanders who will part of the tour
operation and tourists from Australia to
the United States the United Kingdom
China and Malaysia that is to the best
of our knowledge to those who have lost
or missing family and friends we share
in one segment of all grief at this
moment your loved ones stood alongside
Kiwis who are hosting you here and we
grieve with you and we grieve with you
to our Australian family especially
we'll do everything we can to support
you as we have supported us I have been
in regular communication with australian
prime minister Scott Morrison through
yesterday evening and will continue to
do so over the course of the day as
we're able to provide
more information for now obviously our
duty is to return loved ones and as
superintendent Byrd has pointed out
obviously there is much more to be done
Coast Guard medical staff police and
staff of the national and local
emergency management teams and of course
our attorney District Council staff our
hats at this time go out to those who
are injured missing and deceased and
their family if I know and I want to
acknowledge down both our valued
international visitors and local
and our focus right now is on supporting
these people in our broader community
visitors our community is rallying to
support and another ways a wealthy
refuge has been set up by - you're aware
of Nashua at - Manuka to attacking
moraine as a place to share and support
one another at this time other councils
around New Zealand have been incredibly
supportive and I want to thank you very
much
I'm cluding our local councils that are
here today
and I also want to recognize as many
community groups in a week who are
currently offering support wherever is
needed
our community recognizes that the
situation on preparing wine island
remains at level 3 there have been three
eruptions and there is an unpredicted
and so we will continue to work with the
police and the District Health Board to
ensure the best care for our injured and
for an ongoing improvement of accurate
information
thank you know so College like we pay
durable intially we also have
representation through serie from from a
civil defense perspective who are
coordinating the questions we just
confirmed that number that the
superintendent superintendent you may
want to confirm so there's eight people
still missing and you and that is a
definitive that's a final number you
believe and you don't hold any hope that
they have survived on the island the
part they went out the year in speed we
have 45 minutes he's provided a pretty
good indication they believe
else he survived disclosure we also have
the Eagle helicopter up the as well for
a considerable period of time and we
keep no signs of life and did you see
them were you able to see the people who
are missing from the helicopter during
your reconnaissance missions have you
seen them from the air passengers from
the previous one the cruise lines done a
stunning job here until trying to help
reconcile them families are already
traveling from Australia the AFP
that's not something that we've
confirmed numbers around those
individual nationalities currently
affected by the explosion the eruption
obviously that's information that the
police will be looking to confirm
throughout the course of the day and
liaison directly with those
representatives particularly obviously
in Australia a significant interest
which was ended up being treated in
Wellington Auckland middle Todd on
Waikato Christchurch and we also have
engine unfuck attorney that geographical
spread it's an indication of us using
all of the expertise available through
the burns units throughout the country
to make sure people get the most
appropriate critical care but as
superintendent I said that obviously
there are a number who are in a critical
condition and burns being a dominant
injury
we'll be working with the experiences of
said is a scientific and technical group
meeting in Wellington at the moment we
need to be guided by that advice
obviously those who undertook a rescue
effect in the immediate aftermath is so
obviously an incredibly courageous way
even at that time of course that was
extremely volatile as you had genus and
volcanologists say yesterday that in the
immediate 24 hour aftermath they were
expectations or through the potential
further eruptions so again I think all
of us would want to acknowledge the
efforts they week to to ensure that that
everyone that could be evacuated was at
that time obviously were injured were
evacuated and as has been said absence
in no safe way look there's this a
number of questions that I absolutely
expect and anticipate will be asked in
that regard but I think consensus here
is that the focus has to be on those at
this time who are critically injured and
of course what is very sadly a recovery
operation of those questions that people
I EE walk have that the context would
simply provide is that my understanding
is the tourism operations have been
undertaken there for several decades
after 30 years it is being a live
volcano throughout that time at various
times has been to
but it is a very unpredictable volcano
there will be questions that will be
asked in do you need to be answered by
the appropriate authorities and we will
be ensuring that there happens but for
now we focused on on those who are
caught up in this can you can you just
talk us through the numbers again so 31
came off is that is that the correct
number 31 people are in hospital in
hospital and how many have been
discharged so the total of 34 people
came off the island and five deceased at
this point of course making sure that
these are safe distance that people are
maintaining around the perimeter of the
island particularly works as volatile as
it as it is and they'll also be
assisting with any potential
reconnaissance missions all through the
recovery efforts so at the moment an
available resource to the police and
others
the offer of victim identification has
been made obviously the New Zealand
Police have those expertise at their
ready and ready to be deployed as well
so that obviously be in issuing that
between the federal police in New
Zealand police they'll work through that
offer of assistance to speak with the
ash ash obviously significant and we've
had reports of one about returning
without to it can we just talk about the
people you believe are still out on the
island the eight people who are not
accounted for do you know do you know
what age groups they are do you have any
idea we do here
you can appreciate obviously wanting to
make sure that that families know first
and you need to detail that my identify
before families are influential you
understand that the police want to work
directly with any other questions can I
just can I just ask me a Turner how
important is this operation to this
district ten thousand people a year go
out there is set right that seems a
large number and to what extent do you
think it brings people to [ __ ] attorney
who might not otherwise come here
the information I have was one we spec
helicopter to private helicopters in a
volcanic eruption so did the best of my
current information
there was another helicopter in the
vicinity oh I understand was unable to
learn that's my other specs my
understanding but of course very mindful
this is obviously an active operation I
need to make sure that the police and
those with the expertise that obviously
the ones doing doing the job here on the
ground so oh but here just seeing what
additional assistance may be needed and
of course we have a job to do to make
sure that in fact the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs are working to assist on
the ground particularly with those loved
ones who may be coming into New Zealand
and also making sure that people are
receiving all of the assistance they
need within our health system and so
it'll be my immediate focus but
obviously it's over to the police the
operational just looking at a statement
from the Defence Force from last year
they shifted a two point four Tong Tong
shipping container to fiqar e to provide
shelter in case of an eruption do we
know whether anyone used that whether it
was working whether anyone took shelter
in it do we know anything about that but
as the superintendent has described
police sorry the helicopter pilot as I
understand physically moved around the
island rather than just an aerial survey
and did so for some time and so brought
back their report there
fortunately there was no sign of life
alright everyone actually further
updates will be provided as available
thank you